hey Kevin
your gambler right rounder you play the
ponies small horses
I do gamble Michael yeah nothing about
doing some gamble on myself you know
just a little bit of money maybe
doubling it and then doing it several
more times no God just for fun I was
thinking juvett ifs or ideas about sure
things like a boxer who is gonna throw
the big fight you know like he's he's
tied into some crooked dealings and
maybe his kid is sick or something I
could I call about that
[Music]
awesome I'm gonna need to take another
advance on my salary he's always been
terrible with money I bet his Jan
spending them straight to the poorhouse
yeah women be shopping I can't believe
he has a second job it's not even good
at his first one hey guys did you talk
about oh okay
I know what's going on talking about Jim
and Pam if they're having sex what it
looks like an icon thing hey hey hey
Michael are you having money problems
monkey problems no I'm not having monkey
problems why would I have monkey
problems I know you heard me correctly
oh I hate monkeys what's going on why do
you have a second job I don't have a
second job
maybe I am having an affair with Suzanne
Somers doesn't Jan have money I don't
talk to my girlfriend about money
it is brewed and unsexual true it's best
to hide our money problems from women I
totally agree with you but I don't have
money problems at all right you know
what watch this five money problems
would I do this
well yeah yeah but I destroyed it it's
hot it's not even usable anymore because
heard you're having money problems no
you didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away
Creed Bratton has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed Bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Snyder how would that help creed
and monopoly you go bankrupt you lose
you don't go by monopoly man that game
is nuts nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
excited oh I've always wanted to be in
the witness protection program fresh
start no debts no baggage far I got my
name picked out Lord Rupert Everton I'm
a a shipping merchant who raises fancy
dogs that's the life
I declare bankruptcy
you